SpaceX's crewed dragons space capsule
has successfully returned to earth it
splashed down off the Florida coast this
morning earlier about 250 miles above
Africa the capsule undocked from the
International Space Station this
critical test flight paves the way for a
dragon mission carrying astronauts nASA
has relied on Russia for rides into
orbit since the space shuttle fleet was
retired in 2011
Manny Baracus is monitoring the re-entry
from the Kennedy Space Center in Florida
Annie good morning good morning the
splashdown happened offshore about 275
miles east of here recovery ships will
bring it back to Cape Canaveral
now the landing was the last item on the
checklist for this historic week-long
mission SpaceX is trying to prove that
crew dragon can carry astronauts into
space and bring them back down to earth
safely but a Falcon 9 rocket lifted crew
dragon into history last weekend
becoming the first commercially built
and operated spacecraft capable of
carrying people to dock at the
International Space Station it was an
exciting visit for the astronauts there
American and McLane spoke to CBS News
yesterday from the ISS what this is is a
very significant step that marks opening
up at the low Earth orbit to commercial
companies not only to shuttle NASA but
perhaps other customers the only
passenger this time was a test dummy
named Ripley outfitted with sensors to
measure the impact of the ride for its
eventual first fliers NASA astronauts
Doug Hurley and Bob Behnken really this
is about predicting what the vehicle is
going to do and then testing it and
making sure that those two things match
up as you kind of go through this
mission and that's what's going to give
us that confidence going forward flying
people would be a giant leap for Elon
Musk's company which he founded nearly
two decades ago it's been 17 years we're
still haven't washed anyone yet but
hopefully we will later this year so
that would definitely be the culmination
of a long dream for me and a lot of
people at SpaceX for sure
SpaceX could fly astronauts as soon as
July but the company still has a lot of
work to do including testing the abort
system Boeing is also building a new
spacecraft it's called the Starliner and
that company is hoping to launch it on a
test flight like this one next month
Nora I love it
Manny thank you so much